whatever happens with AI a development
at this scale
is a political matter in recent decades
our conception of politics has become
really really shallow and narrow
on the left the the leftists have said
pilot keep your politics out of my
bedroom keep your politics out of my
drug bin keep your politics out of
whatever I want to do socially and on
the right the conservatives have said
keep your politics out of my business
keep your politics out of my bank
account keep your politics out of my
personal life but politics is just what
we do together politics just means
public and and the
the conception of politics at the
founding of our country was a much more
robust conception the whole idea of
self-government is that we're going to
be really involved in politics and we're
going to come to conclusions about the
world and how we want to live and then
we're going to impose them on the
society through our through our vote and
through our elected representatives